les mains vers la vallée serré et si
vous voulez donc le crâne entre les
mains je veux pas d'ossements allez
vas-y les cas je tiens non eric aouita
une telle mini jupe
[Musique]
promis je suis une nouvelle soit avec
vous encore en déplacement au poste avec
tous mes amis chroniqueur pour tous un
physique de ouf et ça va bien nous
servir passé avant de commencer
l'émission pour me détendre un peu
jusqu'à la fin j'étais un peu stressé je
suis encore un peu aujourd'hui j'ai la
chance d'avoir la sublime clio avec moi
vaniteuse mais aussi de nos biens voilà
tradition et donc nous donner quelques
cours le yab en tout cas qui va nous
faire faire des exercices de yoga avec
des positions qui vont s'afficher à
l'écran que vous avez reproduire devant
nous et nous on va essayer de le faire
par duo alors on va commencer à première
position avec la posture da dont ceux là
parce qu'on annonce qu'il va s'afficher
isabelle est une plante qui ça fait de
nous à la temple et moi passions la
danseuse il ya moi la mer vous avez
besoin mais qui au fond n'a
malheureusement ça rendra les attentions
au pied donc on a levé le bras goëlo rue
ils le feront on attrape douce liquide
non droit qui le fait qu'il le fait non
jean michel et ses bons soirs fonctions
actuelles après avoir donné on attrape
la cheville soit oui c'est encore sûr de
concentration sur les 12 mois n'est pas
en avant et on
cette base là malheureusement je me fais
dire mais madame c'est moi qui ai fait
le deuxième exercice fellag la créature
sauvage simplement passer mais ça on est
ici en mélangeant on vient sur le côté
ses projets une salopette au journal
arrière à bas d'après vous et on vient
s'étendre en arrière c'est ici zayatte
hull le pied tout le monde
là tu es un cacique l'instant c'est vrai
c'est le meilleur et pour assurer la
passion du corbeau ouhlala de l'
équilibre sur les bras c'est pas
possible c'est à dire que la tour
revient sur les bras donc la dcri soit
besoin de ses bras non juste la ligne
imposée j'ai eu aucune puissance d'un v6
situé au les bras et au toit vient
christophe aussi mettez-vous en vins
sont à la clé les doigts bien écarter
plan de face le but c'est d'être détendu
un combat bien et ont ramené de me
détendre me lâche peu d'essence et que
sa forme extérieure comme biceps comme
sa villa
on les colle sur les bras les besoins en
eau et ont bien vers l'avant et on lève
les pieds
et ça paye bien clio pour l'arrivée pour
les galas bon la dernière position
eux c'est sur la tête ça s'appelle
thomas tétart joueur du monde va le
faire et ensuite
yaro belle affaire alors ça c'est une
des postures les plus durs mais les
meilleurs pour sentir vraiment bien et
viennent avant l'émission c'est génial
je vais partir je veux mettre les pieds
dans la tête
on va donc mettre les bras vers l'avant
mais la tête est ici
doucement oh la la oulala c'est ce qu'on
veut insister avec c'est très facile ça
non ça c'est vrai moi je ne fais pas
parce que j'ai pas à vous dégoûter
et tout doucement le résident se jeter
d'un pont il
c'est beau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec qui veut le faire encore des
chances de sourire non non non ça ne
serait pas non plus un problème de
serviteur mais pas à aller vérifier
america aussi c'est bon il faut
maintenant ça c'est une très mauvaise
idée qui va fêter chez vous les mavs à
laval est serré et si vous avez donc le
crâne entre les mains je veux pas
d'ossements allez vas-y les cas je te
tiens non eric aouita une telle minutes
bon on se retrouve tout de suite
[Musique]